I don't know why they placed me next to
you that's I want to be so nice to David
for the whole entire flight and that's
been being probably the worst how many
hours is just like 13 hours of his life
there isn't it me so much I had a lot of
dairy last night's on party in your
mouth you know this is our first trip
together it is the original internet
couple when you put David first move
down here Alice's his first internet
girlfriend I know poor choice everybody
thank you very much [ __ ] losers both
of you oh my nipple we travel more than
all of us combined and you always travel
alone do you know what that means
concubines [ __ ] hookers drugs or it
could just mean that I want to you know
do the things that I want to do which is
living Oh which is a lot of women like
you know sometimes I want to see you
know tourist places by myself right
Michael yeah no not like a friends that
do not include you know women are
prostitutes or hookers I'm pretty sure
it's all prostitution it is none of that
none of the above there has to be none
of the above
I highly deny it Japanese one-on-one
putting it to Cuba me sentencing Japan
sometimes I wonder what you would do
without him me yeah everything like what
I believe so but I'm saying he completes
you the sad thing is I modeled my
relationship after YouTube Morel doesn't
like it but soon because she doesn't
like verbal abuse and that's how I am
yeah I know
comment [ __ ] [ __ ] on a daily we what
we would like joke around a little bit
and I call it an [ __ ] and she doesn't
understand the tier of what curse words
mean so she's realized that certain
curse words mean more than other curse
words right so I was like what's up
jackass you look what's up [ __ ] and she
goes I called you a [ __ ] cuz you called
me a jackass
no no jackass is here [ __ ] is all the
way up here that's a fighting word she
was oh yeah she threw me off with that I
was like cuz to her crotch were just
curse words they're all bad none of them
are funny that's what I said is she goes
no it's a curse word to me we're in this
play it honestly looks like a scene at a
battle royale you are all up in my
everything I hate the fact that they put
us together here have some of my girl
your mouth open your mouth open the hood
we're on this plane right now and
honestly looks like a scene in a battle
royale Japanese kid but you murdered I'm
doing one of these how much you bet they
can we got Bart that will felt like a
silverback gorillas us there I think I
could do something you tell me I can't
protect you if I became down to it I
think in the moral want I can I'm
telling you I repay one of the whole
Japanese boys it fingering you asleep
you know this picture should be a go-go
dancer everybody who pays go dance get
your money back right now
oh no push them away push for wiping and
stuff
look at this [ __ ] truck dealer
man all day photo [ __ ] money right
there [ __ ] finally here in Japan it
was a 11 hour flight here I don't know
that a lot of other places a lot further
before me it's a very long time and you
have to realize that those seats are not
made for people above 6 feet so the
headrest was on my upper back it wasn't
on my neck I don't think you're really
sinking that I'm in Japan yet it's been
pretty hectic right now it just kind of
feels like oh you know I'm here but you
know tomorrow's another day
this is my current sleeping place right
now at least I have my own room but of
course as you can see I'm on a futon
that's about 5 foot 8 I am 6 foot 1 my
feet are dangling and it gets a little
cold
over-talk do the world see what else we
could do so y'all didn't understand damn
thing I said did you but I Joe ah I'll
see y'all next time
you